uh rescuers are continuing to search
through the rubble here of the shopping
center which is completely destroyed i
mean there's really absolutely nothing
left of it virtually the entire depth of
the building is completely burned out
after that huge fire that followed the
missile strike yesterday
and rescuers have been working through
the night clearing debris to see if they
can recover anyone uh trapped underneath
i i spoke to
one of the rescuers a little earlier and
she said that they're not hopeful of
finding anyone alive
at this stage and that they have found
human remains so it's very hard for them
uh to get a clear idea of exactly how
many people
died but the official figure that we've
been given from the regional governor uh
is 18
so far and a local police station
not far from here is collecting dna from
relatives who've reported uh loved ones
missing since this attack yesterday now
we understand around half of this area
have been cleared so far it does feel
more like a recovery operation
rather than a rescue operation now but
certainly a very grim
uh attack indeed to have happened on
this central ukrainian city just before
four o'clock in the afternoon yesterday
a busy time uh with lots of people
shopping here
lots of families at the supermarket
and of course this is just the latest in
a run of attacks on uh civilian targets
the russians claim they're not targeting
civilian areas but certainly these
contin these attacks uh continue to
happen